the time has come for me to finally
figure out what's wrong with me thank
you
this is from eka recommended by one of
you guys that I do MBTI personality test
now it's already assumed my gender and
my location disgusting
okay if you want to I'll leave the link
to the tests in the description you can
do the test with me
let's see what's wrong with ourselves
okay I like to stay at home agree oh god
I like to met make definite plans when
going now somewhat I avoid public
speaking whenever possible yes but not
because I don't like public speaking
just because I don't want to do it it
takes up too much time to do it well I
work best in a group or with others
while pub G we know can't do do us I
like to fix things more than I like to
try and fix people
sure I like tests that have essay
questions I don't even know what that is
I prefer to use logic and reason in my
thinking I agree
I like to improvise whenever possible
somewhat sometimes it can be good you
know this is easy morality should be
based on justice agree I like to rely on
my membrane oh I have no memory like a
goldfish you guys should know that I
largely accept things as they are
[Music]
disagree how else are people going to
improve how else are people going to
learn if you just accept things from how
they are hard you're just gonna accept
don't you want a higher standard
disgusting I like to procrastinate yeah
I'm listening procrastinate
I am largely uncomfortable with my
emotions I don't know what that means
I'm bored being alone no I'm very good
at entertaining myself I like to be
focused on the future yeah I like to
talk more than I someone I like to think
that I can balance both you know not be
just okay I like to follow my head more
than my heart as someone I like devoting
my day yeah
shameful shameful okay I prefer hard
data over theory well yeah you need why
not
how can you argue with hard data huh I
like to think I'm thick-skinned I agree
100% how do you think I got here not by
being a little my life is pretty chaotic
well I guess it is but it's not my fault
so I'm gonna go with someone I prefer
looking at the overall big picture yeah
why not
I want people's love who doesn't I find
it difficult to yell at oh there's
someone and no it's not that hard I
prefer to stand out no well I prefer sit
but what do you mean that depends is it
like being different or hey look at me
I'm standing out you know I'll put
someone I like to plan things at the
last minute
No I feel I'm more energetic than
laid-back nope I like to tell people
what an event meant to me personally
rather than just subscribing it yeah
yeah I think it's more interesting to
get why people things are Maureen okay
whatever oh yeah oh yeah I feel like I'm
gonna get the worst result from this I
tend to believe what others tell me
wholeheartedly oh no I like to know wild
things yeah okay we're almost there
we're almost there
I like to keep my options open yes I
like to go out rather than stay home
somewhat somewhat fine I like to perform
in front of others yes I work best when
I'm alone yes I'm gonna be an introvert
great I like to try fix people more than
uh didn't I answer these I prefer to
take a multiple-choice test yeah I think
logic is sometimes overrated who would
say that logic is overrated I like to
prepare for things rather than just
things on the fly someone you're just
asking me the same questions that I put
somewhat on morality should be based on
compassion somewhat I like to make lists
to help my memory oh yeah I can't
remember anything I have to make lists I
have no choice I'm generally unsatisfied
with the way things are no I'm not I
like to get my work done as soon as yes
it's 8:30 in the morning I need time to
be by myself yes
I'm focused on living in here and now
someone I'd like to listen more than no
I prefer to follow my heart over my head
I don't know this is test ever [ __ ]
end Jesus I like to play more than work
hard Oh play hard more than work hard uh
someone I prefer theory over no one I'm
easily hurt by others words shut up my
life is pretty organized I'm gonna sit
with someone no not really
I don't know this is too hard stop
judging me thank you
I want people's respect more than their
love yeah I can see that I don't mind
yelling when I need to yes I prefer to
fit in then stand out yeah okay last
page I like to plan far ahead someone I
feel like I'm more laid back than
anything yes
do you ever meet me in person when I
talk about any event I prefer to keep
the facts rather than describe what it
meant to me you're asking the same
[ __ ] question
I just put stuff wherever it doesn't
need to go in a specific place disagree
how else are you gonna find it god damn
it
I love and get fired up by parties and
social gathers somewhat I'm pretty
skeptical about most things someone okay
I like to know the who what and when no
things yes here we go I am the duty
FULFILLER I am serious and quiet that's
true interested in security and peaceful
living that's true
extremely thorough responsible and
dependable
I'll take it well develop powers of
concentration that's true when I need to
I'm really focused usually interested in
supporting and promoting traditions and
establishments that could not be further
from the truth
I think all of those things are stupid
how did that get in there well organized
and hardworking they work steadily
towards identified goals yep
they can usually accomplish any task
once they have to set their mind to it
that's so true that's so true this is
really I'm surprised how accurate that
description is except this one I don't
believe in in establishments at all and
traditions I think is sort of overrated
maybe I just misunderstood some question
I am more introvert than extrovert wish
I knew I am most sensing than intuitive
I don't know what that means I'm more
thinking than feeling or is it the
opposite
I think that's a good match though you
can't just have one without the other
and I'm judging more than perceiving Who
am I this is really interesting
I recommend testing trying this out I am
is TG let me know what you guys got and
then in the comments I'm curious okay
who else is is TJ Elizabeth the second
George Washington George Bush and of
course Jackie joyner-kersee
what is my weakness I'm stubborn
insensitive come on I'm not now neither
of these things some other sting sting
and Denzel Washington and Natalie
Portman my god
incredible Jason Bourne thorin
oakenshield The Hobbit is a launch it's
my god this changes everything all right
let me know what you guys got and thank
you for watching leave a like if you
enjoyed and squad fam out
[Music]